[موسيقى]
اخبار العالم اجازه من غرفتي اخبار
الجزيره اهلا بكم بيان صيني سعودي يعلن
اتفاق الرياض وطهران على استئناف العلاقات
الدبلوماسيه بينهما واعاده فتح
السفارتيهما في مده اقصاها شهرا كما اتفق
الجانبان على تفعيل اتفاقيه التعاون
الامني بينهما ويؤكدان ان عوده العلاقات
ستعز الاستقرار والامن الاقليميين الرئيس
التركي يوقع مرسوما بتقديم موعد
الانتخابات الرئاسيه والبرلمانيه الى 14
من مايوير المقبل متهما قوى سياسيه
بمحاولات استغلال الزلزال واثارهم
انتخابيه بينما يتعهد مرشح تحالف المعارضه
بحل المشاكل الاقتصاديه الناجمه عن
الزلزال رغم تحركات الغربيه لخفض التوتر
دائره التصعير تتسع في فلسطين مستوطن
اسرائيلي يقتل فلسطينيا قرب قلقيليه
بذريعه محاولته تنفيذ عمليه الطعن
واستنفار اسرائيلي بعد عمليه وسط تل ابيب
اسفرت عن خمسه مصابين والاحتلال يامر بهدم
منزل المنفذ ويعتقل افرادا من اسرته هذا
وتبنت حماس العمليه وتوعدت الاحتلال
بالمزيد الكنيسه الكاثوليكيه في اسبانيا
تواجه اتهامات بتعمد اخفاء الهويه
الاسلاميه لجامع قرطبه الكبير بعد الكشف
عن خطه لانشاء مركز للزوار يرمي لترويج ان
اصول المسجد مسيحيه وتصحيح ما تعده
الكنيسه رؤيه اسلاميه مبالغا فيها لماضي
المدينه الى اللقاء